bonsoir jean paul stahl merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france les est-ce que
vous pouvez nous décrire précisément ce
que c'est que cette maladie de kawasaki
et quels sont ces similitudes a priori
avec le co vie de 19 mais c'est une
maladie inflammatoire qui est connu elle
des pédiatres depuis très très longtemps
sans son incidence est relativement
faible puisque c'est de l'ordre de 5
pour cent mille en état en situation
ordinaire c'est une maladie
inflammatoire qui presque par définition
par nature atteint à peu près tous les
organes elle peut se traduire par des
troubles au niveau respiratoire
également respiratoires ou plutôt
bronchite que pneumonie et surtout ce
qu'ils ont fait la granite et les
atteintes des vaisseaux cardiaque et
donc avec des attaques du haut niveau
cardiaque est aussi bien des atteintes
du muscle cardiaque
le traitement est maintenant assez bien
codifié ce qui faisait dire le très
récemment à la société française de
pédiatrie que les cas vraiment très
grave étaient devenues rares depuis la
mise en route d'un traitement qui est
relativement simple qui utilisent les
immunoglobulines et c'est une maladie
qui est comme le coronavirus est due à
un virus ou pas alors on n'en sait rien
on le soupçonne comme à chaque fois
qu'il y a des ordres inflammatoire de
cet ordre mais pour l'instant on n'a
jamais réussi à mettre en évidence un
virus plutôt qu'un autre voire même un
virus tout court au sens très large du
terme
donc qu'est ce qui déclenche c'est ce
syndrome de kawasaki pour la sambre le
sait pas il y a une une piste de
recherche vers une susceptibilité
génétique parce qu'il y a plus de
syndrome de kawasaki en asie qu'en
europe mais c'est une piste qui pour
l'instant n'a absolument pas été
confirmée alors est-ce que le coc vide
pourrait être responsable de ce genre de
désordres immunitaires
pourquoi pas mais la relation reste
entièrement approuvé pour l'instant
c'est uniquement une piste comme
d'autres virus peuvent être également
des pistes
quand vous dites c'est une piste
finalement c'est une hypothèse qui était
mise parce qu'il ya le coronavirus en ce
moment et qu'il y à une émergence de
cette maladie de kawasaki qui
d'ordinaire est plus rare c'est ce que
c'est comme ça qu'est basé sur le
raisonnement c'est comme celle là dessus
qu'il basait le raisonnement de la
relation entre les deux c'est à dire
qu'à la fréquence du coc vide et tout
d'un coup qu'il ya des cas qui
surviennent de façon anormale par
rapport à la fréquence habituelle
encore faut-il voir si cette fréquence
se poursuit dans le temps parce qu'il
peut y avoir un hasard qui fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de cas un moment et puis
beaucoup moins le reste de l'année donc
tout ça doit être encore investiguer
mais il est vrai que le coc vide comme
d'autres virus encore une fois peuvent
être incriminé mais il reste néanmois
faire vraiment la preuve un rôle
véritable de ceux de cette relation
avant d'alerter la population pour dire
attention attention il ya une nouvelle
maladie qui survient chez les enfants
d'abord c'est pas une nouvelle maladie
est une maladie connue
c'est simplement une fréquence qui
paraît être anormal et qu'il faut
investiguer actuellement est le propre
de malades et pour l'instant nous même
relativement faible et et puis cette
maladie se soigne bien c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de nous dire le traitement
oui le traitement le traitement même si
certains enfants doivent passer par la
case réanimation mais le traitement de
la maladie de kawasaki est plutôt très
bien efficace tel qu'il est codifié
actuellement est ce que les enfants
supporte mieux la réanimer
sion que les adultes puisqu'on il peut y
avoir entre 30 et 40 % de mortalité
suite à ces réanimation oulalala
réanimation ça dépend pour quoi on va en
réanimation
maintenant les dégâts chez les enfants
peuvent être tout aussi importante chez
les adultes
donc je me lazhar devrait pas à dire que
la réanimation chez les enfants est
moins grave finalement que la
réanimation chez des adultes alors vous
lancer cette alerte 1 basé sur une
hypothèse vous vous rendez compte que ça
peut alerter les parents qui doivent
remettre leurs enfants à l'école le 11
mai c'est de nature à les inquiéter
davantage
c'est bien pour ça que je il faut
vraiment n'ont pas lancé une alerte mais
dire que il y a quelque chose qui paraît
anormal mais des quelque chose d'un
ormeaux comme ça on envoie 10 15 ou 20
par an donc c'est pas parce que il ya
quelque chose qui est en cours
d'investigation
kylie a immédiatement une alerte annoncé
s'il ya alerte c'est parmi les
praticiens pour remonter les cas et pour
les analyser correctement mais c'est
absolument pas une alerte de santé
publique qui ferait changer un
quelconque comportement dans la
population générale
merci jean paul stahl d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france